hello everyone and welcome back today we
will be doing yet another systems design
problem probably going to be Amazon
retail now if it looks like I'm going to
pass out that's because I probably am so
I'm going to try and keep this video
relatively short however if you guys are
anything like the women that I've seen
in the past apparently the long ones are
too painful anyways so hopefully this
should be just good for you let's go
ahead and get started all righty so
today we are going to be building Amazon
or for you lovely folks over in India
right now flip cart basically the idea
of this is uh as we know you can go
ahead and see a product once you see the
product it has some price probably an
indication of whether or not it's in
stock a button to add it to your cart
and then of course once you're on the
cart screen you can go ahead and place
an order so as you can see in my cart uh
it shows the items that I've currently
uh got ready to check out we've got some
lotion some socks some motor oil a broom
no relation between any of those items
just random stuff that I picked out cool
let's talk about some problem
requirements
so the main things to do here are we
obviously just want to build some pretty
uh limited feature set of Amazon's
retail site which at least as far as I'm
concerned uh you know what's hard to
build or what's worth building for the
sake of this video is going to be uh the
cart service uh basically dealing with
inventory management um you know dealing
with when items go out of stock and uh
just in general making everything fast
and scalable a couple of features that
we aren't going to cover as far as
Amazon is concerned are the revews uh we
basically did that with Yelp it's the
same idea payments probably deserves its
own video if anything anything related
to Amazon web services you're on crack
if you think I'm covering this in this
video or of course any uh user or seller
customer service related type of things
um I have a friend who works at Amazon
on one of these teams and it just goes
to show you it it deserves an entire
team right so obviously there are tons
of complicated Services going on on
Amazon retail however nonetheless we're
just going to cover a very small piece
of that cool so let's talk about some
quick capacity estimates uh these are
going to be super handwavy because you
know it just changes constantly and
you're kind of at your whim of your
interviewer here when you're doing this
so first off let's assume there are
around 350 million unique products on
Amazon I Googled that one so why not
just round it up to a billion we want to
build for scale uh additionally
apparently there are 10 million orders
per day now we see why Bezos is so rich
that if you divide by your 24 hours your
60 minutes per hour and your 60 seconds
per minute leads us to around 100 orders
per second which is actually not so bad
if you think about it just considering
the fact that most of those orders are
probably going to different databases or
you know different product IDs and those
will probably be spread out over
different databases but we'll talk about
that later the next thing is that I
basically start getting really handwavy
here and say let's estimate we have
around a megabyte of data per product if
we multiply our billion products by our
megabyte of data that's around a
petabyte of of total data so we're
obviously going to be needing some
partitioning over our products database
which is not a huge deal keep in mind
all these products have images uh so at
some point we want to throw them in S3
maybe use a CDN to speed up those load
times and then finally uh regardless of
how much scale that I listed out here uh
if you were just like I'm going to throw
this on one database your interviewer is
probably going to be like you need more
scale than that so uh yeah we're just
going to try and imagine that everything
is uh as slow as possible and that we've
got 10 bajillion users uh editing
everything at a time and we're just
going to try and build something super
bulletproof cool so what is the highle
overview I got a comment recently kind
of uh saying that I should try and
structure my videos a little bit better
so I'm going to attempt to do that with
this very slide uh apparently and I've
heard this in reference to Amazon and
other e-commerce sites even so much as
100 milliseconds of a delay on our load
times can really hurt our conversion
rates in our site and so as a result we
want to make reads as fast as possible
wherever we can especially when loading
potential products actually clicking
into a product to see the view of it and
then you know checking out as well
because we want to make Rights passed as
well cool so if I had to make a table of
contents here for the one thing I'm
going to cover really quickly is our
products database then our card service
then dealing with placing orders and
then finally just optimizing reads in
general cool so the first thing that
we're going to talk about is our
products database so like I mentioned uh
we basically have a petabyte of products
data store or we can imagine that we do
and if that's the case we're going to
have to go ahead and partition this
thing uh additionally we also want to be
ensuring fault tolerance uh and if we do
that even within all of that we want to
make sure that reads are as fast as
possible so generally speaking I don't
really think we have to worry too much
about write throughput here because
editing a product database uh
description is probably going to be
something that like an administrator or
a seller might do and they're probably
not doing that too frequently I would
imagine it's very infrequent that two
people are going to be editing the
description of a product at the same
time and so as a result I mainly care
about our read throughput here and as
opposed to our write throughput so I
think single leiter replication should
be fine I think that um using a b Tree
in theory is going to be optimal because
as we know B trees are just you know go
down the tree D and find your read as
opposed to an SS table where you have to
actually check multiple of these SS
table files and that is obviously going
to take longer of course the B tree is
going to be slower to write to but we
don't really care if we don't have that
many rights to it cool so the another
thing is uh as far as Amazon products
are concerned I think that we want to be
able to have a flexible schema here the
reason being that uh you know products
are in many different types of
departments and uh they have many uh
different pieces of data amongst them
and so having that flexibility could be
useful so this is one of the very few
cases where I'm interested in no SQL
solely for the data model or the
flexibility there and uh I think that
mongod DB is going to be the choice here
considering it is a sing single leader
replicated uh B tree index type of
database and also allows us to just make
Json documents for products I think we
are typically going to want to load that
full Json document at once so the data
locality is actually going to help us
out here and uh we don't really need to
do very much denormalization we're
literally just loading the product it's
not like there's any uh joins that we
need to do at least not in this very
strip down version of Amazon cool the
next thing we can talk about is actually
building a cart so I'm going to discuss
a few different different
implementations of how we can do this
ideally getting better and better as we
go so I guess the same uh the kind of
idea here is we don't just want it to be
the case that one person can edit their
card at a time I might have my account
open you might have my account open we
could both be editing that card at once
and if we're doing that we don't want to
both be stepping on each other's Toes or
just having super slow rights cool so
what would be a really bad
implementation well I guess it would be
taking the full list that you have in
your JavaScript front-end application
and just sending that over to the
database and overwriting the existing
card with it why well for starters if
two people write at the same time and
one isn't aware of the other's right one
is just going to override the other so
if we already had eggs and ham over here
oops did the wrong thing if we already
had eggs and ham in the
database and then this guy writes milk
and carrots that's just going to
completely get rid of it that would be
bad we don't want to step on each
other's toes like that uh of course we
could also just store the cart as a list
and then basically add elements to the
end of that list right so I'm going to
add ham this guy's going to add eggs but
that's not going to be great either
because we're going to have contention
when we're adding elements to the end of
a list we need to grab a lock on the
list itself in order to add that element
and so as a result if we have tons of
people you know not just two guys but
maybe 10 or 20 trying to add to the end
of the cart we're going to have a lot of
contention on this lock now of course in
reality is it going to be the case that
we're going to have 10 people editing
the same Amazon card at the same time
probably not but like I mentioned the
whole point here is to basically push
this problem to the extreme in order to
ultimately think through some
fundamentals of systems design cool so
let's continue talking about building a
cart ideally we don't just want to keep
a list because like I mentioned whenever
we have to maintain order for something
we're going to have to grab locks in
order to append onto the end of that
list so what could we do instead well in
order to avoid having to lock we could
just do a set right so as opposed to um
adding things in list basically what we
could do instead is add things to just a
typical table where you've got your card
ID and your product ID and since these
two aren't actually uh contrasting with
one another we can just throw them into
the table and you don't have to
basically have the two compete with
locks cool however the one situation
where we would have to grab locks is if
we want to be able to delete items from
our cart right so the person who adds
this item right here and the person who
deletes it one is going to have to grab
a lock on that row to add it and the
other is going to have to grab a lock on
that road to delete it otherwise we
would have race conditions and you have
no clue what's actually going to happen
so of course like I mentioned again this
is all going to be super hypothetical
are we ever going to really have a lot
of ads and removes of the same item
within a second probably not maybe I'm
desperately trying to add 20 boxes of
tissues to my Amazon cart and my mom
keeps deleting them because she's pissed
at me buying too many tissues however I
don't really think that's going to
happen in real life but again we're
going to pretend like it does cool so
let's imagine there was a ton of
contention on a single one of these rows
how could we avoid that lock in
contention well generally speaking at
least as far as I've come across or what
comes to my mind when I was making this
video I can think of kind of two main
ways to try and deal with avoiding
contention right so the idea is if we're
going to have to grab locks to write two
things that compete with each other
ideally we have two options one is
basically we process them one at a time
by first buffering them in a sense
calized place like
Kafka in this case I don't really think
Kafka is going to work very well the
reason being that if I add an item to my
cart then it's going to go in Kafka and
be processed asynchronously in the
background so if I add an item to my
cart and then I click check out uh
unless Kafka has already like allowed
that message to be processed now all of
a sudden I'm going to check out a bunch
of items and I might not even have the
one that I just added so that would be
bad we definitely want something that's
going to be at least synchronous here or
synchronous so far as when when I add an
item and then I check out I can see that
I actually added that item and it's part
of my card cool so our second option
would to actually just be to send all
the rights to different places so they
don't have to compete with one another
and in this case when we say different
places what that really means is
multiple database leaders for that
particular card so a couple of things or
complications are going to come up here
if we have multiple leaders how is it
that everyone is going to end up seeing
the same card well they won't there's
going to be eventual consistency but we
can actually ensure eventual consistency
by virtue of using a crdt so these are
something I talk about relatively
frequently on this channel a crdt stands
for Conflict Free replicated data type
and in this case we want to use such a
crdt to build a set amongst our leaders
so the idea is we're going to have a
crdt on every single one of these
leaders each of them is going to
basically have its own copy of what it
thinks is in the cart and then
eventually those guys will sync up with
one another and then they should all
converge to the same value so what I'm
going to demonstrate in the next slide
is something called an observe remove
set which is going to allow us to build
out a crdt set where you can add delete
elements and then add them back which is
not trivial and uh the one thing to note
here is that like I mentioned there are
multiple leaders and so if we do have
multiple leaders in order to avoid the
case where I write an item to a database
then check out and my item is not in the
cart we should make sure that if I'm
writing to a database or writing to a
leader of a dat database one of the many
that I should also read from that same
one so that I can actually see my own
items on the checkout otherwise you you
know basically make it possible such
that uh you know you check out and don't
have the item in there that you just
added cool so hopefully that all makes
sense so far let's go ahead and talk
about this observe and remove set so
basically the overarching idea here for
this crdt is that one it's an operation
based crdt so I'm not going to be
throwing my whole set in the database
every single time I'm just going to be
throwing in the element that I added or
removed and the main idea is that every
single element that I add or remove
we're also going to append some unique
tag which is really just going to be a
random
uuid and basically what we're going to
do is we're going to throw that unique
tag on the product ID whenever we're
adding or removing an item from the card
and that's basically going to tell me uh
what a given client actually knows was
in his version of the crdt when
performing an addition or a removal
so let's go ahead and demonstrate this
let's say that at timestamp one we've
got one client making a right to this
left database over here and he wants to
add product 12 to the cart so we assign
this random tag a32 is that a delete no
it is not at Tim stamp two this guy over
here is going to read from this leader
and sees that uh you know product 12 is
in there with that given tag a32 so now
his client is going to say hey I want to
go ahead and delete this thing how do we
delete a given item well all we have to
do is put it in the database with the
tag 12 a32 and a given delete saying
okay we actually got rid of this thing
cool the next aspect of this is going to
be at time stamp 4 we have yet another
client who says oh you know what I'm
also editing this cart I want product 12
too since this is a unique
addition we're actually going to
generate yet another new tag in this
case 6D 27 and that of course is not
going to be a delete so the main idea
here is that when we eventually merge
together all these operations both
databases are going to agree on what the
general state is so now because of the
fact that
a32 was actually deleted and added we
know that we can basically just cancel
this guy out from both of these replicas
once they sync up so a32 is going to get
deleted but note how this user never
actually deleted product 12 with tag
6027 so this guy sticks around and this
is actually going to be the eventual
result of our crdt we basically would
agree that 6027 was still in the set and
not yet deleted however in an alternate
set of events what would actually happen
is let's say you know uh this guy is
actually going to go fourth and what
happens at time stamp three is this guy
adds
6027 however at time stamp 4 this guy
both deletes a32 and he deletes 6027
because he sees them both he's actually
read from this database first and then
at time stamp 4 goes and deletes them
both well in that case we would have
nothing remaining in our cart he
actually just deleted product 12
entirely so hopefully that makes enough
sense for how you can both delete
products and also add them back the tag
is basically going to be the source of
Truth cool the next thing that we're
going to be talking about here is going
to be our order service so the general
overarching theme Here is whenever we
create an order I have to check whether
there's going to be stock on that order
so how do we check if there's stock well
obviously for each product there's some
sort of counter saying here's how much
inventory I have left you know product
10 has 100 left in stock so if I'm going
to buy five units of 100 or product 10
now I have to decrement that quantity
from 100 to 95 and if you recall every
single time that we have to do some sort
of De
operation or something like that on a
counter we have to grab a lock on it
otherwise we can have lost updates so
for example if I have this counter here
10 and two different processes both try
to add one at a time what that really
means is they first have to read the
current value add one to that and then
write it back so as you can see if they
both do that at the same time without
locking they can basically both read
that the current value is 10 and both
write back 11 that would be a bad race
condition hence the need for the lock
so if we do have to grabb a lock that of
course opens us up to lock contention so
like I said in reality this probably
isn't such a big deal right we mentioned
we have around 100 orders per second
since all of those orders are on
different product IDs uh we're going to
be grabbing different locks for each of
those 100 orders I imagine there's not
really that much contention in reality
however of course for the sake of this
problem we're going to pretend like
there's a ton of contention so what are
we going to do in such a scenario
well let's go back to our avoiding
contention Playbook basically there are
two things we can do one was what we did
last time where we have multiple leaders
and we attempt to basically use some
sort of eventual consistency in order to
distribute out our rights to multiple
different places so that we don't have
to grab as many lock or we don't
basically grab the same locks on each
database node cool so in this case let's
imagine we use something like a counter
crdt so this is something I've covered
in the past but basically the idea here
is that you keep track of um the number
that you have basically incremented on
every single leader instance and then
eventually those guys will sync together
and then you'll have a good idea of the
total number of increments or decrements
in this case but the idea here is
basically we could effectively see the
remaining quantity of orders or at least
as well as each leader database knew it
to be and those guys would eventually
converge however the problem is we only
actually find out the true value of uh
the crdt once these guys actually sync
up with one another so let's imagine uh
I'm just going over to this example
right here and I'll erase what I had so
that I can write it out again let's
imagine that we both start out with 10
remaining quantity on both of these guys
now the first thing that's going to
happen is uh you know let's say one
order comes in it goes to this database
over here and it was for a size of 10
and then this guy comes over here going
to the right database and it was also
for a size of 10 now these guys SN up
and they say Oh shoot what actually
happened is that we oversold our product
by 10 units we accidentally sold 20 and
we only meant to send 10 now we have to
go back and tell everyone that even
though we told them that they had filled
their order they didn't actually so what
would be a better solution than that
well ideally we have to use our other
possibility which is going to be some
sort of buffering our events which we do
in Kafka and then processing them one at
a time via a stream processing framework
so basically the idea now is that the
orders are going to go into a Kafka Q we
can partition these by product ID if we
need to actually scale them out because
there are so many product ideas and then
basically once we figure out whether we
actually have the proper amount of stock
for a given order we can go ahead and
email a user now keep in mind that uh
the emailing users part is not item
potent right so for some reason our
flank node goes down or whatever it is
that we're using for stream processing
uh after we send that email and we don't
actually acknowledge the fact that we
sent the email we're going to rerun this
event from Kafka send another email and
you know tough luck our client gets two
emails but not the end of the world just
note that it is not item potent unless
we use two face
commit cool or it wouldn't be item
potent if we use two- face commit but if
we did use two- face commit it wouldn't
be possible for us to end up replaying
that email because uh we would
acknowledge the message at the same
exact time that we sent the email cool
so I now I have myself a little Di
diagram here to explain how order
processing is going to work when we are
using streaming so we've got our order
service over here this is where I come
and place myself in order you know for
some
tissues and some
lotion now the first thing that's going
to happen are these guys are two
different product IDs right tissues
could be product ID 22 lotion could be
product ID
50 so over here the first thing that's
going to happen is that exact message is
going to be sent into this fairy kfaq
and the nice thing about using one Kafka
Q for the whole order is that that is
going to assure atomicity we know that
once this message is in Kafka it's
eventually going to be processed by the
rest of our components but before it
gets there if I wanted to split these
guys up and try and send them both into
the same Kofa que well it's possible
that one gets there and the other
doesn't and then now we only process
half of our order so again it's very
nice to basically have a unified Kafka Q
for our orders and then once it actually
gets in there we can use flank to
basically guarantee that every single
message is going to be processed so what
our first Flink node is going to do is
actually split up these orders so I'm
going to call this the order splitter
Flink whatever bad name who cares it's
basically just going to Route each
individual component of the order so
each product of the order and the
quantity that we actually want into the
proper Kafka Q for it so these Kafka qes
are shed by product IDs so these would
be the
individual product orders
cool the last thing that's going to
happen there is we're basically going to
take a product ID we're going to take
the quantity of it that we actually want
to buy and then we are going to uh check
its current quantity on the Flink node
so let's imagine I wanted a three
quantity and there were three remaining
what I would do is basically decrement
this three to zero I would send an email
to the client saying you're good to go
we actually filled this order and then
the next thing that I would do is say oh
shoot this thing is a zero quantity
let's go ahead and write that this
product is out of stock to our product
database the last piece of the puzzle is
well how is Flink actually able to cash
the uh basically the current uh stock of
a given product well besides whatever
incoming orders there are it also needs
to get any incoming inventory changes
that come from uh our sellers so what
our seller can do is if this is our
seller he's basically just going to
upload hey uh you know for product 10 we
just added 250 more stock and then this
guy would flow through Kafka back into
our Flint consumer and then this zero
gets edited to 250 so that we can start
fulfilling subsequent orders cool
hopefully that all makes sense right
there the last aspect of this video is
going to be attempting to optimize our
reads so like I mentioned uh basically
the faster that we can make the reads on
our service the more likely that we are
to sell products and that is a huge deal
so the idea is um you know we can't make
all of our reads fast right that would
just be put everything in memory you
know get everything into cash that would
be nice uh so a certain subset of our
items we want to ideally make the reads
faster for so which items would these be
well ideally the popular ones cool so
the first question that should come up
is which items are
popular many different ways to determine
this I'm sure Amazon has a variety even
internally one would just be the number
of orders on a product another would be
the number of clicks on a product etc
etc etc maybe the reviews on the product
it doesn't really matter I guess the
idea is at the end of the day we're
doing some sort of counting
aggregation over a Time
window and we might want to export those
metrics let's say once per day so of
course you already know what I'm going
to say what are we going to do stream
stream processing because then we can
window our data and say hey here are our
metrics for the last day so let's say we
use spark streaming because uh we just
want to process things in mini batches
no reason to process them one at a time
uh it's not that urgent so let's say uh
you know we keep all of these counts in
spark streaming let's imagine that we're
doing this based off the number of
orders on a product right so in spark
streaming right over
here not only are we uh keeping track of
the actual quantity remaining but we're
also keeping track of the number of
orders so we're going to do that and
then once per day at some set time we
can basically export for each product ID
the number of orders that they had and
we can send that right over to hdfs now
once this guy is in hdfs or once all
this data is in
hdfs we can actually go ahead and run a
spark job to basically rank all of the
items in terms of their popularity we
would calculate some popularity score we
would rank them we could even split them
into given departments right so for
example I don't know the silverware all
the mattresses all the video games rank
them all in their own categories and we
could even do some exponential waiting
right if I have yesterday's data and the
days before that I can slightly
incorporate those into my popularity SP
uh score but I could wait today's data
more heavily again this is all
implementation details you have a lot of
options here for how you want to do this
ranking doesn't really matter but the
point that does matter is that once we
know which items are particular po
particularly popular sorry about that
we can go ahead and pre-populate our
caches with them so we can do that with
uh basically the product data that we
see in mongodb we can throw that in a
redus cache for products and
additionally we can take those
corresponding images of the products and
throw them in a CDM the nice thing about
a CDN is of course that it's
geographically distributed meaning that
for a given product ideally since those
images are so big if the CDN hosting the
image is physically closer to me I can
load it
faster cool so another part of reads
that we really want to optimize is going
to be text search so of course if you go
to Amazon one of the things that you're
going to notice is that we have this
massive search bar at the top and uh you
know you want it to be quick when you
say search for a given product so if I
want to search for a mattress I want to
see only mattresses and I want that to
happen really quickly now if you've been
watching my channel for a decently long
time you would know that a search index
is going to be completely necessary here
and what that really is under the hood
is just going to be an inverted index
where inverted index is an index from
search
term to a list of product IDs or product
descriptions that contain that search
ter cool and so uh in order to make
things even faster I said product IDE
over here but what would really be
better is an actual product
description or perhaps a mini one maybe
not everything that's in but
perhaps uh like a thumbnail of the
product because then we don't have to
actually go back to to do an
additional read once we hit our search
index so a little bit of data
denormalization is probably going to be
in order here cool so the next question
is going to be how do we actually want
to partition our search index well we
could do Global term-based partitioning
right which would be super nice so if I
ever search mattress uh all of the
document IDs or the product IDs that uh
contain the term mattress are going to
be on a single note that would be great
because then if I ever do that search I
am basically only going to have to hit
one node at the same time in reality
there are probably too many products
especially when you consider their
description sizes uh in order to be
doing that the reason I say that is
because keep in mind that if we want to
keep a global index what that basically
means is that the same product is going
to have to be on multiple different
nodes right so for example if we have
the term Kleenex on one node and the
term tissues on another node uh on node
one I now have to keep the full product
description and on node two I also have
to keep the full product description so
now we're really really duplicating data
which is not ideal um another thing
about global based partitioning is do we
really need all of those uh product IDs
on the same partition perhaps not
because at the end of the day on our
front end we use pagination so as long
as every single document ID on a given
uh page of Amazon is on the same
partition we can still get super fast
queries cool so let's talk about local
indexing because that is really our only
alter alternative to Global indexing the
idea here is that basically we put a set
of products on every single uh node of
our search index and then we index them
locally so we just build that inverted
index locally right off of that set of
products so let's imagine that uh
basically we have uh one product called
Kleenex
tissues as you can see the term for
Kleenex and the term for tissues is
going to be on this particular node if
on a different node we had I don't know
softy tissues they would also have the
term tissues on that node
too okay cool so that is what local
partitioning is but now the question is
well how do we want to perform local
partitioning we have to decide now which
products are actually going to go on
which node to be locally partitioned
cool and when I say locally partitioned
typo on my end locally indexed great so
what products are going to go on each
partition basically the main thing right
here is that we want ideally similar
product to be on the same partition and
also uh similar product categories which
would be a little bit easier because I
would imagine that in that mongod DB
most of these products are going to have
some sort of tag you know so for an
example a tag would just be a mattress
or it would be gardening or something
like that so similar products can go on
the same uh search index node and
additionally in our batch job keep in
mind we basically have generated a
popularity score for every single uh
product category right so here's uh the
mattress product category we've got
product IDE D2 it's got a score of 3.6
19's got a score of 2.1 and so on and so
on so ideally keep in mind that this is
effectively also going to be the order
of items that we return when we search
for the term mattress and so as a result
what's going to be nice about this is
that as long as we Partition by
popularity score range now if I want to
say search for page one of mattress
listings I basically just want these
terms right here if I want page two of
mattress listings I want these terms
right here and so we can actually just
go ahead and partition those accordingly
which is going to make our life pretty
easily so to summarize that first we
partition the products by their product
category and then internally within a
product category we can Partition by
their popularity score that we calculate
in
spark cool the last piece of this puzzle
is actually going to be doing the
population of both the caches and
indexes after we go ahead and compute
our popularity scores for all of the
products well ideally we don't want to
basically do this into our current
caches and indexes or our current
cluster the reason being that this is
going to slow it down by a lot if we add
a bunch of rights to that current
cluster that is going to compete for a
lot of the networking bandwidth there
and it's going to slow down actual user
reads and that would be bad so ideally
what we could do instead is have some
sort of standby cluster now we don't
have to have this provisioned at all
times but maybe you know 30 minutes
before um our batch job runs you
provision a bunch of ec2 instances or
something like that uh depending on what
platform you're actually using here and
then the first thing that you're going
to do is basically go ahead and populate
them from spark right so you're going to
add stuff into your standby cluster the
next thing that you're going to do is go
over to your zookeeper or whatever uh
coordination service it is that you're
using to basically tell everything in
your application where everyone lives or
your DNS service or anything like that
so we go to zookeeper we say hey wait a
second we're now using all of these URLs
uh that points to our standby
cluster and then all of a sudden we're
going to broadcast that to all of our
existing servers uh via something like a
zookeeper watch in order to keep them
updated in terms of where to actually
Point their queries and then you know
maybe 20 minutes later we go ahead and
decommission uh the nodes in our current
cluster because they can become a
standby eventually we don't want to
waste a bunch of money um additionally
one other point here is you could
probably do this uh on like a region
basis uh where you purposely choose a
time to do this where that region has
most of the people sleeping so traffic
is particularly low uh but those are
other considerations you can just talk
about with your interviewer
cool my voice is starting to give out on
me so give me about one second here and
then we will talk about this okay so I'm
now going to try and demonstrate the
flow of how Amazon is going to work so
the first thing that we can do is
actually just search for Products off a
given search term as we know that means
we're just going to be hitting our
elastic search so like we mentioned
elastic search is going to work really
nicely for us here if we Shard by both
the product type or some sort of product
tag and also some sort of popularity
score range we can evenly distribute
these out pretty easily because we ran a
batch job so we know how big the whole
sample size is and we can distribute
those as
necessary cool the next aspect of this
is going to be the product service this
is once I perform my search now all of a
sudden I see a thumbnail for an item I
want to click the item and get the full
product description so this is going to
be the second thing in the pipeline so
either that product is going to be in
our product cache because we pre-loaded
it there because it's a popular one or
if not we hit our cash get a cash Miss
and then we go over to our product
database which again is going to be
so we get that flexible data
format uh with Json documents and then
we can just Shard that on the product ID
cool hopefully that makes sense number
three is we submit an order actually
technically we would have have to put
things in the cart first so cart is
going to be number three here I've
basically lined up our cart DB so keep
in mind the schema is effectively the
cart ID the product ID and whether or
not it's deleted as well as the unique
tag of that product ID uh so we're going
to do that in ryak uh ryak is not a
database that I talk about super often
on this channel but think of it like
Cassandra but it supports crdts so uh
ryak would work very nicely here cool so
we're going to just Partition by card ID
there uh so that all of the rights for a
given cart are on the same uh node and
as a result of that you know when we do
perform our anti-entropy uh all of our
state will eventually converge cool the
next aspect of this is going to be the
order service so the first thing that
happens as we discussed in order to keep
things Atomic is we send our full order
into the full orders cofaq from there
Flink is going to take it in split it up
into multiple different orders this then
gets sent into a second C Q where we
have orders per product ID with of
course the amount of stock in that
product ID that we want to buy and then
finally that's going to hit our last
Flink node which performs our inventory
checks so this Flink node is basically
going to take in inventory changes which
is just a cofa Q and uh you know if you
are someone who is selling things on
Amazon you can write your incoming
inventory changes to that cofaq for
example product 10 add 250 stock product
10 remove 100 stock Flint can take those
into account the last aspect of this is
that you know obviously once we go ahead
and process whether an order can be
processed or not we would actually want
to send an email over to our user that
made the order so we are going to have
to have the email address associated
with the order somewhere in our data
model finally of course like I mentioned
we want to uh get some aspect of how
popular a given product is so in this
Flink node right here which is sharded
by product
ID
and keep in mind it's sharded by product
ID because Kafka is sharded by product
ID and we have one Flint consumer per
Kafka Shard basically what's going to go
ahead and happen now is that we can
aggregate the number of orders or the
number of stock purchased uh from an
item in a given day upload that to hdfs
at the end of the day and then run our
spark batch job to One update the
products database or rather actually
update the product cache over here
Jordan stop erasing update the product
cache update our elastic search instance
to basically rebalance our partitions by
their popularity score we would do this
in the standby cluster but I just didn't
have enough space in the diagram we
would update zookeeper to basically go
ahead and uh say hey we're going to have
to switch over to our new elastic search
and our new caches and our new cdns etc
etc and uh yeah that would be it right
there once we switch over the user
starts reading from all of those and
particular well guys I hope you enjoyed
this video again apologies I'm so tired
and my voice is giving out however I do
think uh this one was moderately
understandable compared to the Reddit
video so uh hopefully it worked out well
and I will see you all in the next one